وجهت منظمه الصحه العالميه نداء عاجلا
لاطراف الصراع في السودان الانسحاب الفوري
من جميع المرافق الصحيه وعدم اعاقه عملها
ودعت المنظمه في بيان صادر عن المدير
الاقليمي جميع الاطراف في السودان الى
حمايه العاملين الصحيين والبنيه التحتيه
الصحيه والالتزام بحمايه خدمات الرعايه
الصحيه وعمل مرافق الصحه العامه في جميع
حالات النزاع واضاف البيان ان احتلال
اطراف النزاع المستشفيات في الخرطوم تسبب
في تعذر حصول المرضى على الرعايه الصحيه
الاساسيه كما اعربت المنظمه عن قلقها ذا
احتمال اساءه التعامل من طرف الجهه التي
سيطرت على المركز الوطني لمختبرات الصحه
العامه مع العينات المختبريه المعديه شيرا
الى ان المختبره يحتوي على مسببات امراض
مثل الحصبه والكوليرا ومواد خطره اخرى